all right so who's the latest politician
to violate his own covet rules
and get caught for doing it important
qualifier here you know
that is get caught for doing it because
we can assume
that they're all violating the rules
it's just that they don't all get caught
so
the latest is governor gavin newsom in
california
um he went to a party at a restaurant
so that's two levels here what he went
to a restaurant
and it was a party um and uh and i guess
he was caught people found out about it
and here he is pretending to be contrite
a few weeks ago i was asked to go to a
friend's 50th birthday
my wife and i friend that i've known for
almost 20 years and
and a friend that had invite well put a
lot of
time and energy into his 50th birthday
it was in napa which was in the orange
status relatively loose compared to some
other counties
uh it was to be an outdoor uh
restaurant and we started the well the
program started at four o'clock it was
one of those early
reservations i got there a little bit
late at 4 30
and as soon as i sat down at the larger
table i realized it was a little larger
group
than i had anticipated uh and i made a
bad mistake
instead of sitting down i should have
stood up and walked back got in my car
and drove back
uh to my house instead i chose to sit
there with my wife and a number of other
couples that were outside
the household and you can quibble about
the guidelines etc etc but the spirit
of what i'm preaching all the time was
contradicted and i got to own that and
so i want to apologize
to you uh because i need to preach
and practice not just preach and not
practice and i've done my best to do
that
we're all human we all fall short
sometimes
now i saw somebody on twitter point out
that there's a real disconnect
um really in general with this guy but
especially in that clip you just watched
between his facial expressions and what
he's saying
he's supposed to be apologetic but you
don't see that on his face
uh it keeps saying well we all you know
we i made a mistake we all make mistakes
yeah sure we all do make mistakes but
going to a party
while at the same time forbidding the
residents of your state from doing the
same
is not a mistake it's an intentional act
this word mistake is often abused i
think um
a mistake is something you do you didn't
mean to do
right it's like an accident if you do it
intentionally it's not a mistake
so this was an intentional act on the
part of the governor
and we have a right to ask what
motivated this intention like it's not
enough with these with these people when
they get caught doing this whether
they're going to get their hair done
or they're going to a party whatever it
is um you see them walking around
without a mask even while they're
lecturing everybody else for not having
masks on
passing mask mandates and everything um
we we have a right
it's not enough to say oh it's a mistake
i'm so sorry okay great you're sorry
you're sorry because you were caught
but why were you doing it what what what
motivated that we have a right to ask
that
so we could ask with governor newsome
is he suicidal and homicidal does he
really believe that going to an event
like this
might kill someone or himself and he did
it anyway because that's that's the way
he talks
normally if so
you know if he's homicidal and suicidal
that's a fact that might be of some
interest to
the people of california or does he not
really believe
what he says about the virus does he
actually believe that
well sure you mean you you you can be
you know pretty safe
and go to a restaurant go to a party
like it's possible to do
does it is that is that the case which
means that everything he's been saying
about the virus publicly he doesn't
really mean
it's got to be one of those right it's
either he doesn't he doesn't believe
what he's been saying about the virus
or he does believe it and he's got a
death wish
it really has to be one or the other and
uh
that's i i think if there was a real
media
in this country and in california
especially they would ask him that
question which is a governor do you have
a death wish or
are you a a lying hypocrite which one
i think it's probably the lying
hypocrite one
number two a huge scandal here uh the
daily beast has this covered
it says madison cawthorne the north
carolina republican who became
the youngest member of congress in
history has admitted that he tried to
convert
jews and muslims to christianity
my god uh in an interview with jewish
insider the 25 year old who came under
fire for selfies he took at hitler's
vacation retreat in germany
claimed he had converted several muslims
to christ and several culturally jewish
people
catherine said if all if all you are is
friends with other christians then
how are you ever going to lead somebody
to christ if you're not wanting to lead
someone to christ
then you're probably not really a
christian claiming he's read through
just about every single religious work
there is
um the republicans said that he
converted a young woman from new york
and someone quote down in atlanta when
he was in rehab after a car accident the
left and paralyzed
it was pretty incredible hawthorne added
as um
and said he has been unsuccessful in
converting practicing jews
but he has quote switched a lot of i
guess
culturally jewish people but being a
practicing jew like people who are
religious about it they are very
difficult
i've had a hard time connecting with
them in that way okay
disturbing stuff it seems that this
evangelical christian
believes in evangelizing it seems that
this believer in the good news believes
in telling people the good news
it seems that this christian is
christian
incredible revelation i'm glad that
daily beast is on top of this
perhaps next we'll find out that you
know there are vegetarians out there who
like salad
uh bowlers who on occasion will roll
heavy balls towards
small stationary objects i mean it's
impossible to know what surprises
await us after this um by the way if
you've ever been just just a note here
if you've ever if you've ever been
proselytized to
um whether you're a member of a
non-christian religion or no religion
you shouldn't be offended by it or upset
by it it doesn't make any sense to be
offended or upset by it
the person trying to convert you
believes they are telling you a crucial
truth about the
universe and reality um you may disagree
you know you may not believe what
they're saying but there's no place to
be offended by it
you should be offended if they don't
tell you if they
don't share it with you
you know if you've got a christian in
your life who's who's uh
who's not sharing that with you i think
i think that
maybe is where the offense should come
in um
i think that tells you something about
how much they care about you
and for you it's sort of like you know
if you're if you're walking towards a
bridge
and someone thinks that the bridge is
faulty and it's going to give way if you
walk over it
they should tell you that and you should
be very offended
if they don't tell you that even if
they're wrong about the status of the
bridge
like you're walking over the bridge and
there's someone who sees you walking
they stay silent
and then as soon as you make it over
they shout to you oh phew
i thought that bridge was going to give
out well you would be right to respond
dude then why didn't you tell me that
before i walked across
it so you were prepared to just watch me
fall to my death
that's kind of what it's like but in
this case of course it's the other way
around where the christian believes
they're
they are you know they are pointing to a
bridge that will not give way
when they share the gospel they are
trying to steer you towards the sturdy
bridge
um and again even if you don't believe
what they're saying there's no cause
for offense uh any more than you know
in in other religions or some other
religions
there's not as much evangelizing that
goes on christianity is
uh somewhat unique on that front but if
i'm talking to someone of another
religion as has happened and they're
trying to convince me of the truth of
their religion it doesn't offend me
at all um all right
let's go here and and here's another not
so shocking revelation since we're on
the subject of
things that shouldn't shock us another
hate crime claim is has been exposed as
a hoax
it says um
let's see this is from the daily wire
yes clifton utse
18 claimed that his bmw x5 was
vandalized as part of a hate crime
with the perpetrator writing um
every message that left-wing
provocateurs think the right believes
they spray-painted across the suv
racist and homophobic slurs including
the n-word and
kkk was sprayed across
the car as well as anti-black lives
matter messages
i think there was a swastika too
but a month after the initial story
gained local media headlines i never
even heard about this
the owner of the vehicle has now been
charged with multiple crimes in relation
to the incident
uh insurance fraud uh filing a flaw
false claim but bunch of other charges
it's good that they're actually being
charged with a crime for a change
because usually that's not how these
things go
uh faces up to seven years in prison no
way he's actually gonna get seven years
in prison but i would like to see that
happen
if you really want to put an end to
these hate crime false hate crime
claims which seem to happen every week
now um there need to be
serious ramifications for people who do
this
and it is a serious crime you know to my
mind
if you file a false hate crime claim you
should get the penalty
that somebody would have gotten for
committing that hate crime if it had
really happened
so if somebody had actually defaced this
guy's
car with kkk and swastikas and racial
slurs and everything
then whatever whatever penalty they
would get and i'm sure it would be
several years in prison
that's the penalty that this person
should get to my mind
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated